le 7 8 sport numéro 7 bienvenue sur
tvfils si vous venez de nous rejoindre
26 minutes pour un point complet sur
l'actualité sportive avec Anthony
bonsoir Anthony et dans un instant les
images exclusives de l'arrivée du
skipper Versailles est en Guy De Lamotte
il vient d'achever son Vendée Globe et
nous parlerons aussi de hand avec notre
invité sur ce plateau oui patriciables
président du comité départemental de
handball nous a rejoint pour parler
évidemment de ce quart de finale de
Coupe de la Ligue qui accueille mercredi
soir plaisir entre Le Havre et Mios
bonsoir à vous bonsoir bonsoir à vous on
vous entendra dans un instant auparavant
je le disais ces images exclusives vous
y étiez Anthony au sable d'Olonne pour
la fin du Vendée Globe de tanguy de
Lamotte qu'on avait suivi tout au long
de son périple autour du monde tout à
fait après 98 jours en mer Tanguy de la
Motte a enfin franchi la ligne d'arrivée
des Sables-d'Olonne hier matin aux
alentours de 11 heures j'ai pu suivre au
plus près sur le pontau et sur le bateau
tout près de du skipper le final du
premier tour du monde à la voile du
marin versaillé qui s'est révélé au
grand public
il y a 98 jours tanguy de Lamotte avait
ouvert le livre de l'aventure de sa vie
il va pouvoir enfin le refermer avec
fierté
sur les premières prévisions le skipper
d'initiative cœur devait voir les sables
Delon samedi en fin de journée
finalement le versaillais franchira la
ligne dimanche matin la faute a un vent
capricieux et à une monture usée par les
océans
la soirée prévue en son honneur sur le
port et maintenu pour la route une
dernière vacation par Internet avant les
retrouvailles
sincèrement il a fait il a fait une
course géniale il s'est battu il n'a
jamais renoncé
et puis à côté ça il nous a fait plein
de petits postes vidéo il a animé comme
il sait le faire parce que c'est vrai
que on avait l'habitude qu'il le fasse
sur les précédentes mais c'est vrai que
le Vendée c'est c'est une autre
médiatisation c'est voilà et là bah tout
ce que nous on savait de lui en fait est
apparu au grand jour du plus large
public et c'était génial pour ça c'est
incommensurable comme fierté et
maintenant on me demande pas si c'est
mon fils on me demande si je suis son
père donc voilà
je suis son père
son bateau vieux de 14 ans est un
illustre héritage celui de la
navigatrice Catherine Chabot première
femme à avoir terminé un tour du monde à
la voile
sur les pontons sur l'eau et puis
faites bien la fête ce soir mais
gardez-en sous le pied quoi il y a eu
d'autres passages de témoin avant Tanguy
parce que ce bateau est en train de
boucler son 5e tour du monde c'est un
bateau que j'ai fait construire en 98
pour courir le Vendée Globe 2000 j'ai
l'impression que de tous ceux qui m'ont
suivi et je suis pas sûr qu'il y en a
qui va te donner autant d'amour et
d'attention à ce bateau que que Tanguy
qui a qui a fait une course magnifique
avec
le soleil s'est levé il y a à peine une
heure ton Guinée plus qu'à quelques
milles des côtes un silence presque
pesant règne sur le ponton
puis j'ai pas beaucoup dormi donc en
essayant de rien imaginer je suis
impatiente mais je suis tellement
contente de voir toute l'agitation
autour pour lui et il a bien mérité en
fait tout ce qui vient de faire là il se
rend pas compte de ce qui est préparé à
un amant et j'espère qu'il va être très
touché qui va le garder pendant 40 ans
dans son cœur
bonjour après l'exploit du Prince des
Mers François Gabart ils sont toujours
aussi nombreux à communier avec le héros
du jour il y a 12 ans avec cette
performance Tanguy de la Motte révisé le
podium du Vendée Globe il a en tout cas
franchi la ligne dans ses objectifs de
départ pour son premier tour du monde
l'accueil c'est on m'avait dit que
c'était extraordinaire je pense que ça
ça surface tous les tous les adjectifs
qu'on avait essayé de me d'accrocher à
cette à ce moment-là pour me pour me le
décrire donc voilà je m'y attendais pas
il y avait des banderoles sur la ligne
d'arrivée le nombre de bateaux
incroyables
en 2013 le marin versaillé n'est pas
titré mais il aura été le héros de
millions de Français et surtout de 15
enfants ce marin solitaire est aussi
solidaire grâce au clic sur Internet
l'épopée de ton guide de Lamotte a
permis de sauver Gibbs mawa Sérigné et
12 autres enfants
avant la conférence de presse le marin
versaillé a pu déguster son premier
repas à hamburger et une galette des
rois où il a eu la fève de quoi faire la
fête
voir les quatre coins du monde traverser
les océans affrontés le Cap Horn une
collection de moments inoubliables qui
vous changent un homme je fais pas
encore exactement comment mais c'est sûr
que j'ai changé mentalement
on peut pas vivre 98 jours tout seul
sans changer c'est une tranche de vie
extraordinaire et des moments difficiles
des beaux moments et les deux font
changer donc c'est sûr j'ai changé et je
verrai au fur et à mesure comment un
autre tour du monde à la voile pour
l'instant rien n'est arrêté mais le
marin sera sur le ponton dans quatre ans
avec quel costumes celui de skipper ou
de spectateurs son cœur le lui dira bien
assez tôt
sujet de la rédaction de tvfils les
images les interviews signés Anthony
Reich et puis pour le montage Pascal
Joseph voilà pour tanguy de Lamotte qui
devrait prochainement être notre invité
sur ce plateau pour revenir une fois de
plus sur cette exploit 98 jours avec un
bateau vieux de 14 ans pour boucler ce
tour du monde à la voile on change
d'univers on quitte les océans pour
s'intéresser au handball oui on va
revenir sur ce sujet
oui on va revenir un peu sur Terre avec
ce quart de finale de Coupe de la Ligue
1 de handball féminin que va accueillir
plaisir mercredi soir à 20h et pour en
parler avec nous donc Patricia le
président du comité départemental de
handball je voulais tout d'abord savoir
un peu comment plaisir a été choisi
c'est un tirage au sort il y a des
systèmes particuliers au sein de la
fédération alors c'est vrai que c'est la
Fédération a souhaité à déléguer
l'organisation de ces finalités de coupe
de l'île professionnelle féminine olig
parisienne et donc ce sont les
présidents de ligue notamment le nôtre
Georges PATTARD qui a délé gué au
département et au club de plaisir
puisque c'est la salle la plus
appropriée pour cela il y a 1200 places
c'est une superbe salle notamment pour
tvfils parce que c'est très bien éclairé
vous inquiétez pas nous viendrons voir
ce match et les images qu'on a découvert
le lendemain sur notre santé donc on a
confié cette organisation sur les
Yvelines
pourquoi parce que par ailleurs sur les
autres départements il existe d'autres
compétitions ce qui permet d'avoir une
compétition dans chacun des départements
et vous vous le disiez plaisir à une
salle plutôt superbe avec 1200 places et
a déjà l'expérience d'une grande
compétition puisque la salle de plaisir
avait accueilli le Mondial
2016-2017 donc ça avait été une superbe
occasion de voir des équipes
complètement novatrice dans cette
compétition et alors c'est aussi
l'occasion je présume de promouvoir un
petit peu le handball féminin dans le
département oui c'est l'occasion donc
l'idéal c'est de n'avoir que des
spectatrices
j'y crois pas trop quand même mais parce
que les féminines qui sont en évolution
croissante bon reste quand même
représentent pour être 30% de l'effectif
du département c'est une évolution
positive sur ce nombre d'adhérentes
véritablement parce que c'est vrai qu'on
parle souvent en balles féminin on parle
souvent de l'équipe de Montigny le
Bretonneux qui a des fortunes diverses
en fonction des si on a l'une Nationale
2 National 3 retour National 2 on attend
l'exploit pour la nationale une mais
visiblement ce sera pas pour cette
saison bien sûr difficile alors
qu'est-ce qui manque pour franchir un
palier ah je connais très très bien le
sujet là puisque
voilà
malheureusement arrivé à ce niveau-là
c'est un on se heurte un problème
financier donc il faut que les
collectivités soutiennent des politiques
s'engagent véritablement oui c'est pour
moi je pense que c'est un problème de
volonté et puis c'est un problème de
choix également parce que c'est pas
évident dans le contexte économique
actuel donc de parce que de jouer en
championnat de France
enseigneur et en même temps moins de 18
c'est difficile pour le club de Montigny
avec le budget dont il dispose donc on
parle de Montigny mais sur les autres
villes du département c'est la même
situation c'est peine perdue d'imaginer
un club de hand féminin au plus haut
niveau une petite anecdote il se trouve
qu'on a eu un technicien de la région
qui est venu nous rencontrer c'est un
cts détaché du ministère qui est venu
comprendre la situation du handball sur
le les Yvelines et s'est rendu compte
rapidement que de façon on n'aurait
jamais d'équipe de haut niveau pour
quelle raison c'est pour les raisons
purement financières quand vous avez par
exemple et sans faire de polémique
un conseil général qui octroie pour
jouer en
championnat de France 1500 euros à peu
près dans d'autres départements c'est 5
et 6 fois plus donc imaginez les écarts
en fait tout est lié une politique de
Montigny de se maintenir à ce niveau
puisque faut le rappeler Montigny est un
des seuls clubs si ce n'est le seul à ne
pas payer ses jeux par exemple ah oui je
peux vous dire que lorsque l'équipe
internationale il y avait deux équipes
dans la boule qui ne d'animisaient pas
leur fille c'était plus fort mais
Montigny d'ailleurs ce sont les deux qui
sont descendus pour en revenir
ce que vous nous dites là est propre à
l'ensemble des disciplines sportives sur
le département on avait évoqué le cas du
basket par exemple à trappe ils se sont
plein également de ces difficultés
rencontrées et tous les responsables de
club évoquent la même chose c'est une
volonté financière et politique et sur
le département des Yvelines la priorité
plutôt donnée à tous les sports pour
tous les âges c'est un petit peu les
réponses qui sont faites lorsqu'on
interroge les résultats politiques pour
finir sur ce sujet pour en revenir au
match donc de mercredi soir enlever le
rideau aussi il y aura une animation un
petit peu particulière c'est une
animation qui prend de l'ampleur c'est
faire du handball fauteuil donc c'est
vrai que le club de Montigny a été à
l'origine de avec la commune de Montigny
sur ce cette in et comme c'est devenu
une une chose instituée dans le
fonctionnement et d'ailleurs c'est la
seule club de la région Île-de-France
qui a une pratique régulière à tel point
c'est que ils ont été contactés
masculins pour essayer de de faire une
animation des mêmes jours donc il est
pas possible de voir des intérêts aux
Français dans les fauteuils dans les
mois prochains handball du PSG qui
s'approche de Montigny peut-être que
dans le football on verra aussi ça on
attend toujours la décision concernant
le centre d'entraînement des
PSG va évoluer en tout cas au sein de
son centre d'entraînement dans les mois
prochains ou la saison prochaine en tant
que toujours la réponse et concernant
concernant ces deux équipes donc le
Havre est myos c'est deux clubs vraiment
importants du championnat de France vous
avez un favori pour ce match ou pas
alors je serai tenté de penser que Le
Havre est peut-être
de plus de disponibilité pour remporter
la victoire mais rien n'est fait donc
non mais le Havre actuellement doit être
troisième et puis 5e
non je pense qu'on a assistera du beau
handball féminin élégant technique et
c'est quand même très plaisant à voir
voilà vous parliez justement là de
handball féminin élégant et surtout
technique je crois que c'est quelque
chose qui vous plaît plus que Lamballe
masculin qui est un peu trop rugueux
à votre à votre avis maintenant non mais
c'est un style différent j'avoue que
quand j'ai le choix de regarder des
matchs de internationaux j'ai autant
garder du handball féminin que dire de
messe là
sans chercher bien évidemment la
polémique mais ceci mais c'est vrai que
j'ai une sensibilité
peut-être pour avoir développé Lamballe
féminin à Montigny c'est possible mais
j'avoue je suis plus attiré par des des
équipes de jeunes filles que à regarder
puisque ma petite fille fait du handball
aussi que que les garçons mais le hand
juste pour revenir sur cette affaire
justement des départs qui concernaient
les internationaux français ça a joué
sur le nombre de licenciés sur cette
saison à chaque fois qu'il y a une
affaire dans le sport vous le ressentez
une affaire dans le sport en tout cas
sur le hand non non pas du tout vous
avez pas ressenti de de baisse de
licenciaire
des paris truqués et tout ça c'est ça
n'a pas d'incidence sur sur les
effectifs c'est dommageable pour l'image
du handball mais ça fait partie de ce
que j'appellerais des gamineries donc
c'est et d'ailleurs on a eu un point par
notre vice-président de la fédération
qui est un avocat qui suit l'affaire
bien sûr de très près c'est une affaire
qui va se dégonfler toute seule il y a
eu des sanctions qui ont été prises par
les deux les joueurs concernés mais sans
plus
gaminerie qui rapporte pas mal et qui
peuvent aussi coûter de coûter très cher
au club au club et puis aux principaux
intéressés oui les clubs aussi puisque
forcément les clubs leaders qui perdent
leurs joueurs et ensuite sont un petit
peu handicapés
c'est toujours embêtant par les temps
qui courent du monde féminin du Beaujeu
ce sera en tout cas du côté de plaisir
si vous voulez voir samedi soir
n'hésitez pas à venir il faut en
profiter
quand j'ai regardé les compositions
d'équipe
j'ai fouiné j'ai cherché et j'ai trouvé
une joueuse issue de 50 ans en Yvelines
de l'autre côté exactement de Trappes du
côté du Havre c'est ça et oui la
gardienne de but Linda Pradel donc ce
sera l'occasion et c'est une femme très
un peu réservée mais très gentil dans
l'occasion de la
poser quelques petites questions sur son
parcours handball stick d'ailleurs la
garniène numéro 3 de l'équipe de France
elle était notamment championnat
d'Europe
Pradel par exemple voilà tous et toutes
vous attendez un public féminin vous
nous l'avez dit
toutes les places ont été vendues à des
prix complètement modifs donc une sale
pleine normalement vous allez venir
justement les places vendues ça montre
aussi le succès de du handball féminin
nous avons mobilisé
les clubs donc les clubs proches de
plaisir on fait partie de l'organisation
dès le départ donc ce qui les avait
rendu un petit peu motivés par le par le
sujet voilà très bien merci beaucoup
Patrick d'être venu ce soir sur le
plateau téléfil et donc rendez-vous 20h
Mercredi soir mercredi avec du handball
fauteuil pour tous si vous le souhaitez
et les images sont à découvrir sur
tvfils pour cette rencontre de haut
niveau du côté de c'est rappelez-moi les
Le Havre face à news voilà j'ai oublié
la deuxième équipe le temps de retour me
retrouver dans mes fiches on va faire
une petite pause ça permettra justement
d'y voir un petit peu plus clair on va
parler de paquet oui c'était les profs
de rentrer pour l'équipe élite de
triathlon du club de 50 ans en Yvelines
ce week-end le club organisé la deuxième
édition du back and run de la minière
c'était un premier test physique pour
les pour les champions 50 chinois en
pleine préparation hivernale le résultat
avec des images d'Élodie moines
au milieu des 300 participants du
baïkenron de sérieux concurrents à la
victoire peaufine leur tactique de
course en pleine préparation hivernale
les triathlètes de l'équipe Elite du
club 50-îois participent à la fête son
réel objectif de performance on va
pouvoir s'encourager c'est plonger un
petit peu le front celui qui est sur le
VTT il va pouvoir bichonner un peu le
coup à pied et puis voilà l'important
c'est aussi de se faire plaisir de
partager un bon moment avec tout le
monde c'est un petit peu le lancement de
la saison donc ça fait toujours plaisir
de revenir un peu en terre connue ici à
Saint-Quentin
le Bike & Run et l'exercice numéro 1
pour enchaîner les efforts intenses
au-delà des 15 km/h et dans un laps de
temps très court un rythme difficile à
encaisser pour un duo below brandré sans
trop de repère physique au final les
triathlètes incontinois restent maître
sur leur terre le temps
d'impôtsaï s'impose en 35 minutes de
course
c'était difficile dès le début parce
qu'on commence par une côte en fait il y
a une côte de à peu près 600 mètres donc
dès le début il faut il faut se mettre
dans le rythme puis après le parcours
est assez roulant mais du coup ça nous
oblige à toujours courir à
une vitesse régulière et c'est assez
fatigant
huitième à l'arrivée les cadors de
l'équipe élite en termine les jambes un
peu lourdes on a la caisse on manque
encore un peu de vitesse mais du coup
c'est peut-être ce qui nous a pénalisé
aujourd'hui mais bon c'est pas trop
grave c'est pas toi Thomas qui t'a
limité un peu ouais c'est peut-être
l'état de fraîcheur par rapport au aux
autres concurrents mais bon c'est
c'était aussi le but de venir ici faire
une bonne séance voilà la victoire il
tenteront de la décrocher lors du
premier Grand Prix de France fin mai et
faire rentrer le club de 50 ans en
Yvelines dans le top 5 France
passo résultat Anthony vous êtes prêt
pour nous donner de l'essentiel du sport
de ce week-end du football tout d'abord
le soleil faisait son retour sur les
pelouses 50 chinoises ce weekend une
éclaircie qui n'a pas empêché Guyancourt
de sombrer à domicile dès le premier
quart d'heure de jeu Lina Montlhéry
ouvre le score sur le un cafouillage de
la défense centrale pour la suite de
cette première mi-temps c'est une
compilation de fautes et d'action
manqués par les rouges et jaunes malgré
un but refusé pour hors-jeu côté
Guyancourtois en seconde période les
joueurs de Detienne rider encaisseront
deux autres buts score final trois buts
à zéro et on passe donc dans les autres
joueurs dans le football dans les dans
les autres matchs du week-end trap s'en
est c'est en revanche imposé à
l'extérieur de but à zéro face à colombe
en Division d'Honneur Versailles que
l'on voit apparaître sur le tableau à
partager les points avec Les Mureaux
concernant le match nul à domicile deux
buts partout au classement de Promotion
d'Honneur malgré en défaite les joueurs
de l'ES Guyancourt restent leader avec
trois points d'avance sur l'entente
parisienne il conserve quelques
longueurs d'avance voilà le tableau de
Guyancourt voilà ils ont désormais 34
points dans la poule B que l'on vient de
voir trap confort sa troisième place
avec 33 points et mets les Trappistes
restent à 7 longueurs du leader
Porcheville et on revoit ce classement
trap 3e du rugby à présent 14e journée
de Fédérale 3 plaisir c'est incliné sur
la pelouse de pour ton combo dans un
match encore une fois très fermé 9 à 6
autres club un poto combo qui vise les
playoffs en fin de saison les joueurs de
Philippe Béart pourront se consoler avec
le point de bonus défensif il reste à
égalité de points avec Vitry à la
quatrième place à quatre journées de la
fin de la saison régulière tout est
encore jouable néanmoins pour les
playoffs on en parlait tout à l'heure on
parlait de hand justement du hand
féminin oui et plus près de chez nous à
Montigny 15e journée de Nationale 2 les
féminines de Montigny se sont imposés
avec la manière à la maison face à
Fleury Loiret 24 buts à 21 dont 8 buts
de Gabriel parloir encore une fois elle
reste 5e de Napoléon désormais 10 points
d'avance sur le premier relegable de
quoi voir venir du tennis de table à
présent National 2 troisième journée de
Nationale 2 assez contrasté pour les
clubs 50 chinois et l'encours c'est
logiquement incliné chez Leader jouer
les tours 10 matchs à 7 mais pour
l'entendre voisins Saint-Arnoult que
nous avions reçu sur le plateau label
aventure continue les joueuses de
geoffrey's an sont imposés à Nice très
facilement 10 matchs à trois au
classement les joueuses vicinoises son
deuxième avec 7 points à égalité de
points avec Fontenay quant à Élancourt
l'équipe est quatrième avec 6 points
mais rien n'est joué après après trois
journées le maintien est quand même en
bonne voie pour les deux équipes 50
images après les juniors et les cadets
qui n'avaient pas perdu leur match de
début de saison c'est du foot US du côté
d'Élancourt et bien les seniors à
présent aussi fait lors des buts début
plutôt réussi oui il l'avait annoncé
hein c'est c'est le c'est le titre de
champion de France cette saison est bien
les Templiers pour leur retour dans
l'élite on n'ont pas manqué tout
simplement ce retour les joueurs de Manu
charé se sont imposés chez les
Spartiates d'Amiens 21 points à 14 une
victoire qui lancer leur saison et puis
une dernière information c'est de la box
éducative à la fin nous avions reçu le
directeur sportif la semaine dernière
justement du Boxing de la verrière et
sur ces championnats régionaux catégorie
cadets deux titres encore une fois un
haribambelle continue du côté de
Gennevilliers Oumar Diallo en moins de
68 kg et Ilyes Kamal chez les moins de
80 kilos l'emporte facilement finale
merci Anthony pour ce point complet sur
les sports il nous reste encore quelques
instants alors on va pouvoir revoir ce
reportage que vous avez réalisé à
l'occasion de l'arrivée de tanguy de
Lamotte le skipper Versailles sans plus
attendre les images montage du sujet
Pascal Joseph
il y a 98 jours tanguy de Lamotte avait
ouvert le livre de l'aventure de sa vie
il va pouvoir enfin le refermer avec
fierté
sur les premières prévisions le skipper
d'initiative cœur devait voir les sables
de lunes samedi en fin de journée
finalement le versaillé franchira la
ligne dimanche matin la faute a un vent
capricieux et à une monture usée par les
océans
la soirée prévue en son honneur sur le
port est maintenu pour la route une
dernière vacation par Internet avant les
retrouvailles
je suis tout près mais je suis pas
encore là donc garder des forces pour
demain
sincèrement il a fait il a fait une
course géniale il s'est battu il n'a
jamais renoncé
et puis à côté ça il nous a fait plein
de petits postes vidéo il a animé comme
il sait le faire parce que c'est vrai
que on avait l'habitude qu'il le fasse
sur les précédentes courses mais c'est
vrai que le Vendée c'est c'est une autre
médiatisation c'est voilà et là bah tout
ce que nous on savait de lui en fait est
apparu au grand jour du du plus large
public et c'était génial pour ça c'est
incommensurable comme fierté et
maintenant on me demande pas si c'est
mon fils on me demande si je suis son
père donc voilà oui je suis son père
son bateau vieux de 14 ans est un
illustre héritage celui de la
navigatrice Catherine Chabot première
femme à avoir terminé un tour du monde à
la voile
faites bien la fête ce soir mais gardez
dans son pied quoi il y a eu d'autres
passages de témoin avant Tanguy parce
que ce bateau est en train de boucler
son cinquième tour du monde c'est un
bateau que j'ai fait construire en 98
pour courir le Vendée Globe 2000 j'ai
l'impression que de tous ceux qui m'ont
suivi et je suis pas sûr qu'il y en a
qui ont donné autant d'amour et
d'attention à ce bateau que Tanguy qui a
qui a fait une course magnifique avec
le soleil s'est levé il y a à peine une
heure tanguiner plus qu'à quelques
milles des côtes un silence presque
pesant règne sur le ponton
essayons de pas rien imaginer je suis
impatiente mais je suis tellement
contente de voir toute l'agitation
autour pour lui et il a bien mérité en
fait tout ce qui vient de faire là il se
rend pas compte de ce qui est préparé en
amont et j'espère qu'il va être très
touché et qui va le garder pendant 40
ans dans son cœur
un jour après l'exploit du prince des
maires François Gabart ils sont toujours
aussi nombreux à communier avec le héros
du jour il y a 12 ans avec cette
performance Tanguy de la Motte aurait
visé le podium du Vendée Globe il a en
tout cas franchi la ligne dans ses
objectifs de départ pour son premier
tour du monde
l'accueil c'est on m'avait dit que
c'était extraordinaire je pense que ça
ça surpasse tous les tous les adjectifs
qu'on avait essayé de me d'accrocher à
cette à ce moment-là pour me détour me
le décrire donc voilà je m'y attendais
pas il y avait des banderoles sur la
ligne d'arrivée le nombre de bateaux
incroyables
en 2013 le marin versaillé n'est pas
titré mais il aura été le héros de
millions de Français et surtout de 15
enfants ce marin solitaire est aussi
solidaire grâce au clic sur internet
l’épopée de ton guide de Lamotte a
permis de sauver Gibbs mawa Sérigné et
12 autres enfants
avant la conférence de presse le marin
versaillais a plus déguster son premier
repas à hamburger et une galette des
rois où il a eu la fève de quoi faire la
fête
voir les quatre coins du monde traverser
les océans affronter le Cap Horn une
collection de moments inoubliables qui
vous change un homme je fais pas encore
exactement comment mais c'est sûr que
j'ai changé mentalement
on peut pas vivre 98 jours tout seul
sans changer c'est c'est une tranche de
vie extraordinaire et il y a des moments
difficiles des beaux moments et les deux
font changer donc c'est sûr j'ai changé
et je verrai au fur et à mesure comment
un autre tour du monde à la voile pour
l'instant rien n'est arrêté mais le
marin sera sur le ponton dans quatre ans
avec quelle costumes celui de skipper ou
de spectateurs son cœur le lui dira bien
assez tôt
et voilà pour ce sujet avec tanguy de
Lamotte merci Anthony on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine même heure pour un
nouveau point complet sur l'actualité
sportive oui n'hésitez pas à commenter
le 7 8 sport sur Twitter et nous donner
tous les résultats de vos clubs à lundi
prochain bonne soirée